-And I'm so excited
to have our first guest.
He is a best-selling author
and the Emmy-winning host
of "All In with Chris Hayes"
which airs weeknights at 8:00
on MSNBC.
He also hosts the podcast
"Why Is This Happening?"
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend, Chris Hayes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-How are you?
-I'm great!
This is great!
-Isn't it nice?
-It really is.
-We should note,
you've been on the show a lot,
but we looked back,
and the last time you were here
was the day of the inauguration.
And you had to sit
on the other side of the couch.
There was nobody here.
-That's right.
At that point,
COVID was only traveling 5 feet.
-Yeah.
So COVID would go,
but it would just lose steam
and like -- yeah.
-Right there. It's over there.
-So what would happen is,
in between, the crew would come
and clean up all the COVID
that had landed
between the desk.
-Exactly.
-So, we talked kind of --
inauguration about
how it felt like
we had just avoided a car crash.
Ad so, it wasn't a situation
where you felt joy,
it was more like
adrenaline and excitement.
Now we're nine months in.
It also does not feel
particularly joyous right now.
-Yeah, well, I think
there was a real --
For me, there was
a kind of a window of joy,
which was that post --
when I got the vaccine in April.
-Yeah.
-We hadn't been hit
by delta yet.
My brother got married.
He had delayed this wedding.
An actual wedding,
it felt incredibly joyful.
And then I think --
A huge part of it
was just delta coming back.
-Yeah.
-And watching this play out,
and the really needless human
suffering that came with that.
And then, I think, also,
this feeling of, like,
you know when you're
troubleshooting something,
and you unplug it
and plug it back in,
and you're like,
"Please, just work."
And it's like, "Oh, the error
message is still there."
-Yeah.
-And it feels like that
a little bit with, like,
American society.
-Yeah.
-It's like, "Oh, right.
The error message
is still there."
Delta's still there,
the deep divisions,
the incipient and blossoming
authoritarian anti-Democratic
movement capturing
one of our two parties,
the anti-vax disinformation,
all of that is still there.
And I think just
dealing with that,
and dealing with the fact
that we're living through
this period of extended
abnormality is really hard.
-It also -- you know,
the results of the election,
obviously, was something,
I think, that gave some of us
a great amount of hope.
And then the result for
the people who were upset,
it seemed like they've been
very coldly efficient
in using that loss to sort of
gird for this next election.
And is it as troubling
as I think I might worry
that it's going to be?
-I'm pretty worried about it.
I mean, I think --
One thing to think about here
is that --
One thing I think we've learned
is that the way democracies work
is through a kind
of social consensus
about the winner winning
and the loser losing.
And when you take that away,
you're faced with something
much more perilous.
And then when you take that way
and then you're faced with
someone that
wants to essentially
create a litmus test,
a defining issue around
this "stabbed in the back"
narrative, you know,
you're dealing with stuff
that's, like, really, really
dangerous to American democracy.
And I think --
You know, human beings
are really good at adapting.
I think I said this before on
your show in the midst of COVID.
But it's, like, you know,
we're just like,
"Oh, well, January 6th happened,
and, oh, yeah,
once-in-a-century pandemic.
You know, "What can I watch
on Netflix tonight?"
It's like --
-Yeah.
-But that stuff is real, and
it's urgent, and it's present.
And I think it's hard
to sort of see it for what it is
just day by day.
-You know, one of the things
that Democrats have this
very small window to do,
it strikes me, before midterms,
is show people that they're
a party worth governing.
-Yes.
-And it strikes me that
this bill right now,
the Build Back Better bill --
Bad name, right?
-Yeah. Not great.
-No.
I feel like we correctly said
"Be best" was a terrible name
for Melania's --
-Nothing beats "Be best."
"Be best better."
-No, but Build Back Better
is, like,
only a little bit better
than "Be best."
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-But, you know,
we've talk about it.
We had Senator Elizabeth Warren
here yesterday.
And a lot of people have framed
this bill as a number, right?
$3.5 trillion.
-Yeah.
I think that's a thing
that people on the street
could tell you far faster
than they could tell you
what is in this bill.
Have Democrats done a bad job
telling this story?
Has the media done a bad job
reporting this story?
-I think it's three things.
I think it's --
the media has done a pretty
bad job of telling it.
I think Democrats have not done
a great job, as well.
But the weird thing, though, is,
this is all reverse engineered
around the procedural
imperative.
They get one
reconciliation bill -- right? --
To avoid the 60-vote threshold
because they don't want
to get rid of the filibuster,
at least Manchin and Sinema
and maybe a few others don't.
So that means everything's
got to go in the one bill.
So then it's very hard to
message a bill that's got
six or seven
different things in it,
which,
under normal circumstances,
you could pass, like,
"Here's our elder-care bill
and our child-care bill
and our climate
and utility bill
and our carbon-free bill,
and our paid-family-leave bill.
All that stuff is good stuff
that would be popular.
Instead, it's all
put into a blender,
and you've got the, like,
Build Back Better smoothie.
[ Light laughter ]
And it's a little hard, I think,
to sell that
partly because of this weird
procedural constraint.
The other thing I'll say about
the price, it drives me insane.
-Yeah.
-If I said to you,
"Okay. I have one thing here
that's $27 and this is $65."
It's like, which do you want?
It's like, "I don't know."
"Oh, well, this is a bunch
of rat carcasses for $27."
"Well, I don't want that."
And like, "This is actually
an apartment in New York City,
two bedrooms, 65 bucks."
Like, "Yes, please,
give that to me!"
-Yeah.
-The price means nothing
without an awareness
of what's in it.
And I agree that that has really
come to define what the bill is.
-And, obviously now, you know,
I think there's a frustration
for people who would say,
"Hey, you guys are in charge.
You have the House.
You have the Senate.
You have the presidency.
Democrats, what's your problem?"
But the reality is,
the Democrats have the Senate
not only by a razor-thin margin,
but it's a kind of a miracle
they have
50 Democratic senators.
-I mean, we -- I think for that
period between Election Day
and January 5th,
which was the day
that those two Georgia
senators were elected,
I think the expectation was,
it was gonna be
McConnell's Senate,
nothing was going to get done.
It was maybe not being able
to confirm any nominees.
The fact they have
the majority is a miracle.
The fact they passed
the American Rescue Plan
as quickly as they did
is sort of a miracle.
So when you take a step back,
you think,
"Where do you think you would be
in December
before those
two improbable victories?"
and we're in better shape.
The other thing I always
say to people is, "Look,
you're asking full consensus."
Like, if I took 50 people from
this audience, and were like,
"What movie
should we watch tonight?"
you could not get them to agree.
-Yeah.
-When you're 15 family members,
you're like,
"What should we eat for dinner?"
-I will say,
I could get 50 of them to agree
"The Old Scottish Detective"
was a dud.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I could find --
maybe even 100.
We'll be right back
with more from Chris Hayes.